so we bought in a fine wheel and on the
fine wheel some would be money some
would be
um payback of money and some would be
things like um spin again for someone's
car to be valid so you spin again
whatever number it comes out your number
he now has to pay for your car to be
valid nice um one that was a good one
one went down um they have to buy dinner
for you either you and a mate you and
your partner whichever wife whatever it
may be family of course someone tops it
don't they so someone hits the big one
bottle of shampoo and all that yeah well
you know they're screwing because the
bills coming in like 400 now I love it I
don't know what happens then the
receipts presented to that person that
person yeah
no no that's just an example
um we had to sit in a there's a river by
the training ground would have sit in
the river for a minute
last dance lap dance hilarious
well if you've got a lap dancer you'd
have to spin again so it's your fine to
get the number of so when you do the lap
dance genius